[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien une chose que je comprends pas
quand je reçois votre livre c'est
pourquoi ne pas avoir signé botton
puisque c'est toujours votre nom
aujourd'hui avoir signé noir
compte tenu des accusations que vous
portez dans ce livre contre votre père
je pense que ce livre d'abord c'est une
histoire entre mon père et moi tout
simplement
pensez que ça a plus de sens avec noir
c'est mon nom je crois que j'étais
mariée quatre boutons vous appelez
botton y est séparé je suis marraine mon
mari oui et pourquoi vivre aux états
unis
écoutez quand on voit ce que j'ai vécu
ce que mes enfants vécu il ya un moment
il fallait dire stop
voilà et mes enfants souffraient
terriblement et moi aussi
donc j'ai préféré tout coupé coupé les
ponts et dans les réflexions près les
enfants à l'école
ouais moi c'était trop ça n'allait plus
alors vous êtes aux états unis donc vous
êtes bookeuse dans une agence de
mannequins c'est ça travaille dans le
milieu de la mode
ouais t'es là vous êtes en france donc
pour la sortie de ce bouquin alors vous
it effectivement j'ai écrit ce livre non
pas pour régler des comptes mais pour
dire stop
mais en fait la sphère bouton l'a un peu
oublié est en fait c'est vous qui la
remontée à la surface parce que il ya eu
la sortie du livre de pierre botton
qu'on a reçues ici d'ailleurs mais
disons que la sphère elle est enterrée
là pourquoi d'un seul coup ça laissait
vraiment je vous dis encore une fois
c'est entre mon père et moi je crois
qu'il ya une il s'est passé des
événements il s'est passé que je suis
donc parti il ya 3 ans et l'année
dernière au mois de février
mon père a envoyé quelqu'un à l'école de
mes enfants
voilà et ça m'a beaucoup choqué par
courriel contact avec vous oui enfin la
personne était ma soeur elle m'a dit je
sais pas peut-être une dizaine de fois
c'est je suis pas l'envoyer tu n'as pas
donc voila voila et si vous voulez c'est
arrivé après je me suis rendu compte que
ça arrivait à un moment qui pour lui
était crucial puisque après par la suite
j'ai appris que
il rentra en politique oui c'est voler
dans ces grandes salles dé chercher à
renouer avec vous pour finalement
relancé sa carrière politique pour pour
arranger pour s'arranger qu'à la rangée
que effectivement il est c'était une
caution mais moi je ne me servirai pas
de caution bien alors ce bouquin est
très intéressant parce qu'on voit
finalement toute cette histoire racontée
par quelqu'un qui a été témoin numéro un
c'est le cas de le dire donc au début on
voit c'est assez guillerette ou sa
première campagne électorale toute la
famille s'y met pour répondre au
téléphone vous mettez des tracts dans
les enveloppes enfin tout ça et c'est ce
qui est assez joyeux et dès que votre
père était lui le regard des autres sur
vous changent effectivement vous donner
la fille du député vous dites vous
donner un mini toit en parlant de votre
père donc on voit bien déjà le la
première rupture elle est là c'est à
dire que d'un seul coup on vous regarde
plus comme avant une rupture vous savez
à l'époque je crois que c'était pas du
tout perçue comme ça on était très fier
de ce qui se passait on n'était pas du
tout au contraire on était très impliqué
comme effectivement je le raconte on
faisait la chaîne pour une enveloppe
ensuite on allait distribuer moi j'étais
vraiment une militante j'ai affiché pour
lui j'ai fait un coup de choses et c'est
pas ça la rupture je crois que la
rupture elle est venue plus tard bon on
va en parler
donc ensuite on voit l'arrivée de pierre
botton dans le cercle familial première
altercation violente avec votre père
quand vous lui annoncer votre volonté
d'arrêter vos études et d'entrer dans la
vie active et là effectivement d'un coup
le papa gentil devient assez hard est
une espèce de bousculades entre vous
il vous dit tu vas continuer ses études
et si tu le fais pas je refuserais que
tu t'appelles plus longtemps noir ou
c'est vrai que d'un seul coup le mec
c'est un peu le premier il vous a mis à
la porte vous a demandé de lui rendre
les clés de la maison alors en 86 vous
avez 21 ans
votre père devient ministre vous
commencé à fréquenter et d'une façon un
peu plus assidus pierre botton avec qui
vous travaillez puisque effectivement
vous quittez l'école et vous quittez vos
études vous donne un boulot de de
secrétariat auprès de lui et botton
pierre botton finira par vous demander
en mariage je comprends partie des
problèmes avec votre père donc déjà on
sent bien que ça
il est toujours des problèmes la fille
aînée l'école avec son père se battrait
c'est pas quelqu'un si vous voulez chez
nous il n'y avait pas de dialogue avec
l'inscription il n'y avait rien c'était
un père très autoritaire
apparemment oui trés trés tyrannique
mais je pense qu'il faut le dire et
c'est vrai que vous racontez des
vacances à saint tropez ou lui il joue
du violoncelle et il fait régner un
ordre de faire parce que ça le dérange
oui non mais vous épousez quand même un
des plus proches collaborateurs de votre
père c'est à dire que malgré ce ils ont
ces problèmes qu'on sent arriver vous
vous épousez un proche collaborateur
donc effectivement ça pouvait arriver où
c'est arrivé non retourner je crois que
c'était totalement différent quand j'ai
épousé la personne que j'aimais voilà
c'est tout c'est ça n'a aucun n'avait
rien à voir avec mon père c'était
totalement différent de nouveaux
problèmes surgissent lorsque vous vous
mariez effectivement avec pierre botton
c'est à dire que la cérémonie vous avez
l'impression qu'elle est transformée en
opération de relations publiques pour
lui complètement donc il se sert et
c'est tout ce que vous lui reprochez
finalement dans ce bouquin c'est de se
servir de tout le monde qui fait passer
sa carrière politique avant tout 1
et parallèlement à ce que je disais en
commençant il tient un discours sur la
morale sur le fait qu'il faut pas vendre
son âme etc
il tient officiellement un discours très
très humanitaire est très voilà et puis
quand on voit la vie privée c'est tout à
fait différent en 88 votre père michel
noir perd son ministère il n'a plus
d'appartements de fonction il va dans un
appartement rue de solferino qui est
payé par pierre botton et il dira plus
tard au juge qu'en fait c'est un
appartement qui vous était destiné et
que vous n'aviez pas pour un caprice
comme ça vous ne vouliez plus ça fait à
m tout au long de cette affaire il ya eu
1 1 des allers retours entre lui et moi
c'est à dire que le juge faisait
trier entre ce que disait la fille ce
que disait le père parce
qu'effectivement mon père se rabattait
systématiquement sur moi il s'est servi
d'eux vous aussi pour sa défense on va
le voir
la même année les relations donc ses
88es relations se dégradent entre
michèle noiret et pierre botton nous
sache je crois que ça c'est entre eux
déjà on ne sait pas c'est pas quelque
chose que je peux mais c'est vrai que
c'est je pense que mon père est
quelqu'un qui utilise les gens
complètement
c'est un vrai je dirais c'est un pur
politique voilà l'utiliser et après
quand il ne peut pas se regarder dans la
glace c'est dire j'y suis arrivé moi
même
fait le ménage plus ou moins plus ou
moins bien plus ou moins avec la classe
mais c'est quand même une médaille alors
bon finalement pierre botton fini par
quitter ses fonctions à l'hôtel de ville
de lyon
mais avant il demande à votre père de
lui signer l'ordre reconnaissance de
dette puisqu'il est financée toute son
expérience ne sais pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé
ah bon c'est pas du tout je veux dire le
la reconnaissance de dette est ce qu on
appelle ce qu'on a appelé le protocole
est un document que moi j'ai vu arriver
chez moi à un moment où donc
pierre était parti et c'est quelque
chose que mon père a écrit et envoyé
comme ça et c'est pas du tout je veux
dire on n'oblige pas michel noir à
écrire quoi que ce soit et alors là bon
ce qu'on apprend dans ce bouquin c'est
que votre mari pierre botton vit une
aventure il vous cocufie 1
il vit une aventure avec la fille d'un
personnage important de la république
dont vous citer le nom dans votre
bouquin et là vous vous êtes désespéré
évidemment où c'est tragique pour vous
et vous écrivez trois pages sur un
agenda trois pages qui seront produites
par votre père vous l'écrivez dans un
moment de déprime et c'est tout le coeur
de la faire c'est page que vous écrivez
dans un engouement ce moment comme ça
d'abandon seront produites par votre
père à la barre pour pour sa défense en
fait ouais alors votre mari il a des
ennuis pierre botton il se retrouve en
prison en garde à vue à puis après en
prison vous appelez votre père pour lui
dire attends tu peux pas laisser pierre
mon mari est un ancien collaborateur en
prison et vous découvrez en fait qu'il
n'a aucune envie de défendre il vous dit
la police possède des éléments très
vague il a fait des conneries donc
excuse moi mais plus personne ne peut
rien pour lui
il vous demande même de vous séparer de
votre mari et je crois que mon père a eu
dans toute cette histoire une attitude
purement égoïste
il a essayé de si vous voulez me
récupérer effectivement à un moment qui
était qui était important pour lui
il a souhaité faire ce que je raconte il
a souhaité faire un noël en 1992 pour
les enfants parce que j'ai deux enfants
et donc il m'a demandé de venir et de
participer à noël je suis allé et mon
père a souhaité une parler donc je l' ai
vu et m'a demandé de divorcer et donc je
suis parti avec mes enfants voient là et
là donc j'ai entendu pas mal à mon père
votre père michel nouaille
on la commence à accuser botton il dit
en fait si j'ai eu des relations avec
lui c'est uniquement parce qu'il était
mon gendre l'appartement de la rue de
solferino en fait s'il n'était pas pour
moi même si bouton de payer 1000 été
pour ma fille donc pour vous à ce
moment-là botton remet au juge cette
fameuse reconnaissance de dette est en
fait en dix ans et c'est là le coeur de
la sphère il dit en fait je n'ai signé
ce papier que parce que botton me
menacer de quitter ma fille et elle se
serait alors suicidée
et pour prouver ses dires y produit et
c'est bien tous deux l'objet de votre
bouquin il produit ses trois pages que
vous aviez écrit comme je le dis dans un
moment d'abattement en découvrant en
découvrant vous étiez cocu même le juge
ait choqué quand votre père sort c'est
sur ces années je crois que tout le
monde a été choqué c'est un acte qui est
inqualifiable
c'est pas ça si vous voulez je pense que
le rôle d'un père c'est quand même de
protéger ses enfants mais pas des
enfants au monde pour s'en servir comme
bouclier et je pense que c'est ce que
mon père hafez il a sacrifié sa fille
pour essayer de s'en sortir alors qu'ils
ont en face de lui il y avait toutes les
preuves et si vous voulez plus dense est
dans cette histoire enfin je veux dire
il y avait trois pièces étaient de
l'être et je veux dire il a il a lu que
ce qui l'arrangeait donc
c'est un petit peu en fait le dos au mur
pour se défendre pour pour assurer sa
défense le dos au mur il finit par
produire ces lettres alors en plus ce
qui est horrible c'est que ces décès des
documents vous aviez confié à votre
grand père votre grand-père bon était
vieux était malade et un jour il vous
appelle et des coups tu devrais venir
récupérer ses papiers et vous découvrez
à ce moment là que votre propre mère
avait soustrait ces pages de l'agenda à
votre grand père donc elle les avait
évidemment il avait donné à votre père
pour qu'ils utilisent dans son procès
alors le truc est bizarre à votre
bouquin c'est que vous semblez plus en
vouloir à votre père qu'à votre mère jeu
quand on lit le bouquin c'est kampot
merckx avait volé ces lettres chez votre
grand père ac c'est ma mère qui
totalement appris appris ces documents
mais si vous voulez ce que ce que je
vous savez entreprendre quelque chose et
avoir une utilisation tél il ya une
différence
jeudi ils pouvaient très bien les
prendre et puis pas les utiliser surtout
que c'était pas c'était quelque chose
qui avait été écrit un autre moment
oui vous étiez dans l'avion voilà c'est
qu'ils n'avaient absolument pas été
écrit au moment où soi-disant il a été
écrit le protocole a donc si vous voulez
alors au tribunal la production de ces
led vous vivez ça vous c'est normal
comme un coup de poignard d'un se
couvrit les sortir ces lettres que vous
aviez confié à votre grand père vous les
voyez sortir en plein en plein prétoire
vous comprenez bien à ce moment là que
votre père vous sacrifier la politique
et vous prenez la décision de porter
plainte pour pour vol contre
à l'époque j'avais parlé plaint trop
vite tout à fait vous savez j'ai ce jour
là je crois que le ciel m'est tombé sur
la tête quoi ça marche ça a été
l'horreur à l'horreur parce que je
pensais pas que cela il était capable de
faire beaucoup de choses mais je pensais
pas qu'il était capable d'aller si loin
après donc c'est un mec très décidés à
faire n'importe quoi quand même alors il
a fait de la prison votre peur ou quoi
là il crée a été quittée de match où il
a été il a complété condamné à de la
prison avec sursis il a été condamné
surtout je pense que c'est la chose qui
me touche le plus à cinq ans
d'inéligibilité et il aimerait
financièrement une amende si je compte
il ya une petite amende
donc en fait rien quoi si ce n'est
l'inéligibilité et pire que tout et puis
de toute façon je ne souhaite la prison
à personne justement justement votre
mari pierre botton banc en prison et le
calvaire pour vous continue parce que ce
qui est terrible c'est vraiment un
calvaire c'est le cas de le dire c'est
que quand vous allez le voir en prison
il vous reproche des choses il vous il
vous dit que vous êtes de mèche avec les
autres enfin c'est à dire il vous dit un
jour j'ai plus confiance en toi
oui mais ça je crois que vous savez on
la prison est quelque chose qui qui
détruit tout ce qui détruit tout repère
qui détruit absolue pour tous il vouera
complice des autres oui qui va se figer
inaf une tentative alors le bouquet ce
que vous faites va voir celer tout le
monde comme écouter c'est normal je suis
inquiet quand elle son mari tente on
peut dire que vous vous essayez de
alors vous appelez tout bon toute la
journée d'exil vrai que c'est très dur
pour des gens qui ne sont pas prêts à y
aller quand même
c'est plus facile que tu vas tous les
quinze jours que tu t'habitues crédit
tout le monde et ouais mais que t'es pas
du tout habitués et que tu tiens un joli
30 dit c'est vrai que ça détruit les
gens ça c'est sûr alors vous vous allez
très loin parce que non seulement voir
celer bon les gens du rpr extra mais
vous allez voir chirac un génie les
bains alors après on nous le reproche à
bernard pons qui vous a perdu quelques
places et qui allait déranger le plus
dans le public mais vous êtes unique
vous êtes une femme qui aime on comprend
ça très bien non non on puisse aller je
crois que quand quelqu'un est capable en
plein meeting électoral devant un
parterre de plusieurs milliers de
personnes
quand vous êtes enceinte de descendre de
l'estrade de vous emmener
à votre voiture de vous raccompagner
dans un moment où il a besoin de vous
jacques chirac
si vous voulez moi j'étais tellement
désespérée que je me suis dit je vais je
vais aller le voir c'est mon dernier
espoir jeu
il faut qu'on passe à autre chose et si
vous voulez je suis pas allée de vers à
l'elysée non plus je suis allé voir à un
endroit qui était discret et j'ai eu une
fin de non recevoir
alors que quand c'était utile ombre
accompagnait on embrasse est devant tout
le monde et j'étais la petite cocotte de
tout le monde alors la bombe avoue
partir aux etats-unis avec pierre botton
votre mari mais lui quand il revient en
france il nous l'a raconté ici
d'ailleurs quand il revient en france
non seulement il a plus droit de sortir
de france
et en plus ça pue le droit de rentrer
aux états unis donc il est resté en
france et vous vous êtes là bas comme on
l'a dit aujourd'hui vous êtes pas
divorcer mais séparés il ya une chose
aussi en lisant votre livre qui est
étonnant si vous semblez plus facilement
pardonné à votre votre mari qu'à votre
père c'est pas une histoire de pardonner
ccc je crois que ce livre il est
vraiment entre mon père et moi c'est
tout c'était vraiment pour pour essayer
de faire comprendre ce que j'ai subi
je veux dire je suis tombé vraiment très
très bas gg ça a été terrible pour moi
et j'essaye de remonter et si vous
voulez je voudrais vraiment mettre un
point d'arrêt tout cela c'est à dire que
je ne laisserais pas recommencer à
m'utiliser c'est pour ça je ne laisserai
pas reviens me chercher comme ça en
m'envoyant quelqu'un jeudi pendant des
années mon adresse a toujours été dans
les procédures
mes enfants n'ont jamais reçus de cartes
pour noël n'ont jamais reçu de cadeau de
noël depuis 1992
park est déjà dans votre premier enfant
né il vient avec clinique et déjà vous
le trouvez pas débordant d'amour pour
eux pour l'enfant non pour l'enfant oui
c'est ça parce que il était même il
n'était même pas capable c'est en
campagne électorale il avait ce terme il
appelait l'enfant quand il parlait à
quelqu'un parce que de peur de se
tromper de sexe et de prénom et je veux
dire il a appliqué sa petite fille juste
quand elle est née alors que c'était
c'était quand même un moment de joie
pour tout le monde alors quand votre
père essaie de reprendre contact avec
vous donc par l'intermédiaire de votre
soeur vous pensez que c'est une
stratégie pour les législatives de 2002
parce qu'en 2002 michel noir va être de
nouveau éligible donc effectivement la
question se pose
et vous vous croyez pas vous croyez pas
qu'il puisse avoir lâché la politique
non parce que je crois que c'est
vraiment un homme politique et que la
seule chose qu'il fait vivre et c'est la
politique je pense qu'il l'a il l'a
montré il l'a montré depuis en plus dans
cette affaire il a montré que c'était la
politique avant tout alors maintenant
vous avez fait ce livre pour sûr qu'au
cas où voudrait continuer à se
représenter
éventuellement ces pour bloquer sa
carrière aussi où c'est pour c'est bien
je vais vous dire c'est vraiment pour
que la vérité soit écrite noir sur blanc
et qu'on puisse cuir vomi donc si jamais
vous voulez continuer non mais moi je
moi la question je sais pas je me dis je
me dis la question que se posent les
gens qui ne regardent en ce moment est
ce que vous êtes sympas qui continuent à
être inéligibles bien sûr la femme c'est
de sa vie donc est ce que c'est une une
revanche qui ont un poids ou un boulet
mettra son pied ou est ce que c'est
juste pour mettre un terme comme vous le
disiez d'ailleurs être c'est pour mettre
un terme et si vous voulez pas sa
carrière aussi le nom pour mr non c'est
pour vraiment blessé sérieux terme on
peut être très certainement vous savez
tout a été niée dans cette affaire donc
je suis mais c'est vraiment pour pour
que moi je puisse recommencer ma vie
mais c'est une thérapie pour vous voilà
c'est fait je veux dire c'est ma
thérapie c'est jésus des médecins j'ai
je pense essayer absolument tous les
médicaments pour essayer me relever
j'ai deux enfants je veux pouvoir aller
de l'avant et si vous voulez moi je veux
par ce livre vraiment tourné la page et
montrer que je n'oublie pas parce que je
pense que oublier c'est accepter qu'il
recommence bien parce qu'on tient dans
votre tête vous pensez qu'un espoir de
réconciliation c'est justement est ce
qu'on peut vous éteignez la lumière chez
vous est ici aussi
alors les rhinois ont la seule question
finalement que j'ai envie de vous poser
pour terminer ce soir
est-ce que vous pardonnerai jamais à
votre père est ce que vous envisagez à
un moment quand même le pardon ça existe
sur cette paire est ce que vous pensez
que vous lui pardonnera je ne crois pas
il a gâché ma vie et j'en veux plus
voilà
[Musique]
en reparler de l'afghanistan puisque
nous recevons maintenant latif hauteur
de visage volet avoir 20 ans à kaboul
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
latifa bonsoir je vis bonsoir vous et
traduire oui oui vous êtes la présidente
de l'association afghanistan libre et je
dois dire que noël mamère est un des
seuls hommes politiques en france à
avoir été présent à la manifestation en
faveur des femmes afghanes le 29
septembre dernier revoilà alors donc
latifa publie chez anne carrière
un livre qui s'appelle visage volet
avoir 20 ans à kaboul qui raconte la vie
avant et après le pouvoir des talibans
interview vérité
[Musique]
on
latifa vous êtes né dans une famille
aisée de kaboul
votre mère était gynécologue votre père
était dans l'import export et vous est
la dernière de cinq enfants
vous êtes né en 1981 ce qui veut dire
que vous n'avez connu que la guerre
alors dit à force de vivre dans la
guerre nous étions devenus indifférents
à la tragédie de notre pays nous étions
anesthésiés au point de ne pas voir
arriver
l'ultime menace les talibans c'est à
dire que derrière cette guerre il y
avait quelque chose d'encore plus graves
qui arrivait alors jusqu'à l'âge de 16
ans et malgré le fait que votre pays
soit dans la guerre vous avez une vie
assez insouciante
d'une certaine façon qu'ils mangent
jusqu'à l'âge de 16 ans j'avais une
adolescence à souciant tu
j'étais à quelques mois de passer mon
bac à l'orias j'avais des amis garçons
fille et surtout j'étais mais je m'étais
inscrite à la faculté de journalistes
pour devenir journaliste oui c'est vrai
qu'avant l'arrivée des talibans vous
participiez des rencontres sportives des
rencontres culturelles
vous parlez de mode avec vos amis vous
aviez au cinéma vous vouliez devenir
journaliste effectivement ça fait partie
de ce que vous êtes partie de ma vie
avant
mes 16 ans et en parler de mode avec les
avis sur tout on écoutait beaucoup de
musique la musique c'était très
important pour nous voilà et pendant ce
temps là avec l'aide des américains et
qui est des usa le pakistan venait en
aide à la mise en place des talibans
maradona l'avait dit avant je
m'intéressais pas beaucoup à la
politique je dois le dire ça me dépasse
un petit peu je m'intéressais pas mais
voir ces étrangers dans mon pays ça m'a
permis de m'intéresser un peu plus à la
géopolitique et voir ces étrangers sur
notre sol est voir d'où il venait ça ça
fait encore plus mal effectivement alors
le 27 septembre 1996 les talibans entre
dans le cadre houle
les écoles sont fermées les femmes sont
humiliés insultés enfermé est obligé de
porter ce que vous portez ce soir c'est
à dire le tchadri cherche à débaucher
canada guy nadon 27 ans c'est vrai que
c'était le jour qu'il a basculé l'avis
de toutes les femmes à cabo toutes les
jeunes filles et cette ville est devenue
une ville en deuil
du jour au lendemain et moi j'étais plus
latifa de la veille j'ai changé en un
jour effectivement comme toutes les
jeunes filles 27 septembre 96 alors ces
talibans sont pas tous afghans ni même
tous patchoune il ya des pakistanais il
ya des arabes
ils ont une chose en commun c'est d'être
barbu et d'avoir une barbe qui doit
mesurer la longueur de la main
megan tandy nationaux doivent acheter
sur tout ce qu' ils ont aussi c'est un
regard atroce c'est affreux qui vous qui
vous glacent le sang seul instant il
suffit de croiser son regard et je peux
vous dire que vous l'oubliez plus jamais
la première chose qui vous étonne
vraiment c'est que les talibans exhibe
la dépouille de l'ex président najib ou
là qui a été lynché avant d'être pendu
et vous le voyez avec des cigarettes
enfoncé dans la bouche et des billets
qui dépasse de ses poches et pour vous
c'est un spectacle ignoble c'était
encore plus ignoble de voir ça et
surtout la sauvagerie des talibans
puisque docteur n'est du goût là
qu'était le président et qui est un
pachtoune et qu'il pensait qu'avec les
talibans ils allaient tous trouvé un
allié et le voir reconduit dès le
premier jour ça nous a montré à quel
point ils sont capables du pire ces
talibans et puis viennent les consignes
des talibans les décrets respecter
l'avalanche des interdits les filles et
les femmes n'ont plus le droit de
travailler à l'extérieur les lois
commencé à venir les unes après les
autres
pas seulement pour les femmes mais aussi
pour les hommes parce que le sort des
hommes étaient payés pas mieux non plus
parce que toute l'administration étaient
fermées donc les hommes non plus n'avait
pas le droit de travailler puisque
aucune administration ne fonctionnait à
part le ministère de la promotion de la
vertu et et vi alors
les femmes ne peuvent plus sortir sans
être revêtue du tchad riz et sans être
accompagnées d'un homme alors imaginez
les chars de toutes ces veuves qui
depuis 18 années de guerre parce
qu'avant les talibans y avait dix huit
années de guerre qui n'avaient pas
d'homme et qui n'avait pas de mari ou
pas de frère avait perdu imaginer le
sort de ces femmes à quel point elle se
faisait humilier et toutes ces femmes
qui pour exister dans la rue simple pour
faire une simple course a besoin d'une
présence masculine
il y en avait pas dans les familles de
kaboul n'est pas dans toutes les
familles 13 ans masculins alors fini le
maquillage fini le rouge à lèvres fini
le vernis à ongles et si on porte du
vernis à ongles on peut avoir les doigts
coupés
c'était un des des histoires rapportées
par une de mes amies proches j'ai rêvé
vu justement les doigts coupés de cette
femme et moi je vous raconte l'anecdote
de la était cette femme avec ses
chaussures blanches mais la première
fois que je suis sorti dans la rue et
qui ce qui m'a décidé de ne plus sortir
dans la partir de ce jour là c'était de
rencontrer cette femme dans la rue qui
se faisait attraper par ces fous et
rempli de plomb au pied parce qu'elle
portait des chaussures blanches qui
était la même couleur que la couleur des
drapeaux des talibans et qu'il fallait
que ça devienne rouge comme c'est comme
avec la couleur de sens où aucun médecin
homme ne doit toucher le corps d'une
femme et comme les femmes ne peuvent
plus travailler
elles ne sont plus soignés donc elle
meurt médecins ne pouvaient toucher des
femmes et
moi même c'est à juste un exemple de
faire soigner jésuite jesús quitté
kaboul pour partir à peshawar au
pakistan pour me faire soigner parce que
le médecin n'avait pas le droit de nous
toucher ou nous soigner interdit
d'écouter de la musique interdit de
faire des photos d'archivés de la
musique était interdite dès le début ce
qui nous a le plus touché nous les
jeunes parce que ça faisait partie de
notre vie quotidienne
mais malgré ça on n'avait qu'à notre
résistance était d'écouter de la musique
clandestine a dit que d'avoir des
cassettes étaient à l'intérieur de la
maison après au ventre en écouter quand
même la musique alors les non musulmans
sont obligés de revêtir des vêtements
jaune ce qui rappelle ici de bons
souvenirs interdit de vendre des sous
vêtements féminins
ces objets étaient considérés comme des
objets profane est alors le plus
étonnant pourquoi interdit de sifflets
et de posséder des bouilloires sifflante
ça rappelait l'allèle les sons musicaux
et ça rappelle pour eux c'est hélas la
voie du sapin interdit de posséder des
chiens ou des oiseaux et vous êtes
obligé de dire adieu à votre chien bingo
non seulement j en ai dû se séparer de
nos animaux mais sachez que le sort de
beaucoup d'entre nous étaient bien pires
que ces animaux dont on était obligé de
se séparer
voilà et puis à le tchadri donc avant
les talibans quand vous voyez des femmes
revêtues du tchadri vous les appelez
lier les bouteilles vous les ateliers
les choux fleurs à l'envers vous
appeliez les sacs à provisions
moquer de ces femmes c'est pauvre femme
avec mes amis pas seulement moi mais mes
amis jamais on était loin de se douter
qu'un jour on serait nous mêmes des
choux fleurs
alors au début vous restez chez vous et
puis voulait pas sortir vêtus du tchad
riz à kaboul
et puis un jour devant l'insistance
d'une amie vous essayez et vous dit ce
n'est pas un vêtement c'est une prison
d'abord la seule quand je discutais sa
jeune fille beaucoup de jeunes filles
pas les femmes nous agit mais surtout
les jeunes filles
il faut vraiment qu'on attend d'une
excuse pour se faire soigner ou une
vraie excuse pour sortir de la maison
parce qu'on se dit sortir d'une prison
dans une autre au moins dans la nôtre à
l'intérieur on n'est pas obligé de venir
vous frappez humilie alors qu'avec notre
prison le shérif
on n'est pas l'abri de l'humiliation
quatre mois donc après l'arrivée des
talibans vous sortez enfin et vous dites
pourtant ce qui prouve votre état
d'esprit vous dites si mon futur mari me
demandait de porter un foulard ou un
tchador hors de la maison j'accepterai
sans problème et une mort seulement de
marché mais la pression déjà le tchad
heures quand je faisais ma prière dans
mon coin
donc effectivement je suis une musulmane
et croyants pratiquants oui nous devons
partager le même point de vue et savoir
pourquoi je le porte
et pour rien au monde je perdrais aucune
autre de mes libertés
et puis elle est violent un jour trois
jeunes filles arrivent chez vous pour
être soigné par votre mère d'une façon
clandestine et vous découvrez à ce
moment là qu'elles ont été victimes non
seulement de viols et de mutilations
illégal jeune arrière de bunker au zoo
games a choisi sénat vous donne que
wattignies et xena by which had been à
me connaître
j'ai déjà eu effectivement qu'on était
capable qu'on pouvait un être humain un
homme pouvait être capable de traiter
avec autant de violence et de haine une
femme
ces quelques je vous assure qu est
inimaginable temps qu'on le voit
paraître c'est lyon peut pas imaginer
qu'un homme peut faire autant de mal et
gratuitement pendant ce temps le
ministre de la santé des talibans est
reçu à paris dans le pays des droits de
l'homme
et quand vous apprenez ça quelle est
votre réaction maman tu mama rosa gauche
et à la fraude et au goodwood amis en
mode visiblement ravi la bouche mais la
radio clandestine cette époque là donc
c'était notre seule occupation ainsi
d'écouter cette radio de chercher les
informations
je vous raconte pas la tristesse des
gens à kaboul de voir cette propagande
faite par les talibans de voir ce
représentant tellement qu'ils étaient
reçus dans un pays européen qui puisait
le pays de la démocratie des droits de
l'homme je peux vous dire qu'ils ont
fait de la propagande pour nous dire
qu'ils ont été reconnus ici et là vous
quitter l'afghanistan avec votre père
votre mère et une amie une fatwa est
lancé contre vous est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez peur de cette fatwa à bout
d'un nadal j'ai moins peur pour moi pour
moi plus j'ai plus peur pour toutes ces
femmes qui m'ont choisie pour venir
porter leur message ici et qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui la bae dont j'ai eu aucune
nouvelle jusqu'à ce qu'elle devienne
c'est pour elle que j'ai plus peur parce
que celles qui sont en danger
latifa aujourd'hui des gens en france
vous regardent des gens à l'étranger
vous regarde dans beaucoup de pays du
monde
qu'avez vous à dire aux gens qui vous
regardent dans un bar est un moment car
on y avoir deux membres à son côté exane
à vendre des tomates annexes prends moi
je suis un affichage de leur dire que
jusqu'à quand ce silence cette
indifférence contre la femme a même qui
aujourd'hui souffrent là bas on continue
la femme marianne c'est une femme aussi
comme n'importe quelle femme dans le
monde si un jour ce sort vous touche
ça m'étonnerait que vous acceptiez ce
sort ligh je pense que vous serez bien
content deux camps soient toutes les
femmes dans le monde vienne vienne vous
aider le gamin d'instinct il a laissé ça
fait longtemps ça fait trop longtemps
aujourd'hui l'afghanistan et les argons
surtout les avis des ânes ont besoin qu
on panse ses blessures aura lieu si
quelqu'un vous poser des questions à
latifa noël elisabeth philippe orlando
titom c'est absolument terrifiant et moi
je tire on peut que que
vous exprimer notre respect et notre
solidarité vous demandez ce que nous
pouvons faire nous citoyens pour vous
pour vous aider cet accord va la montée
des besoins d'éducation salle à madinani
de ce dont nous voulons aujourd'hui en
afghanistan
aidez nous à voir la paix dans notre
pays pour qu'on puisse se reconstruire
déjà aujourd'hui vous allez nous avons
des zones niveau un instant pourrait
très bien rodé depuis des années déjà
vous pouvez aider c'est au-delà c'est
aussi un combat comme un autre sur de
poser des questions à latifa d'abord je
ne comprends pas comment vous avez pu en
arriver là c'est une question cruel
peut-être mais la femme toujours eu au
sein de la société
un pouvoir même si c'était un pouvoir
cacher il ya un pouvoir sur les sur les
maris un pouvoir sur les frères ya un
pouvoir sur les ficelles donne la vie
donc elle est quand même l'intermédiaire
absolument indispensable d'une société
comment se peut-il que c'est un tel
pouvoir qui est qui et lanteri nation de
la lutte dans l'essex au dans le sens le
plus barbare puisse être s'être
installée voilà ma question je comprends
pas je ne comprends pas je mange des
aliments sont arrivés au pouvoir en
afghanistan il y avait déjà des huit
années de guerre derrière ce peuple donc
il y avait déjà dix huit années de
guerre derrière ce peuple donc le peuple
était détruit avec l'invasion soviétique
et quand ils sont arrivés il y avait
déjà un peuple détruit les talibans pour
la plupart sont des jeunes prélever tout
tout petit et qui sont élevés dans des
madrassas en dehors de tout tout amour
maternel en dehors de toute présence et
qui ne savent absolument pas ce que vous
dire l'amour et la chaleur d'une famille
donc forcément c'est là où on fabrique
cette haine chez ces hommes là des
talibans ne se sont pas révoltés contre
cet état de fait
parce qu'en même sans leurs femmes et il
est bon d idole femmes les hommes et les
femmes se révoltent tous les jours
contre les talibans et ne serait-ce qu
on est quand même aujourd'hui au bout de
cinq semaines
armée comme l'armée américaine n'arrive
pas à toucher les talibans nous ça fait
sept ans qu'on se bat contre les taliban
et contre le terrorisme et nous avons
quand même des zones libres où il ya 5
millions de personnes qui habitent
on continue à construire des écoles des
hôpitaux et à donner du travail aux
femmes et ça veut bien dire qu'on a
réussi là où aujourd'hui il est plus
grande armée du monde échoue des hommes
talibans vis-à-vis des femmes
parce que s'ils détruisent toutes les
femmes mais comment ils vont se procurer
comme en iran contre la dynastie s'était
pas c'est pas du tout c'est une
machination de l'état l'immense et les
pakistanais aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
reçus par le quai d'orsay ce sont aussi
les arabes d'arabie saoudite et les
émirats puisque c'est les trois pays qui
reconnaissent le régime des talibans où
ils ont leurs ambassades
aujourd'hui et le but c'est pas de
prendre le laissez pas de progrès ou
quoi que ce soit le but c'est de
reprendre le territoire afghan
donc le meilleur façon de détruire une
nation c'est détruire sa femme donc par
la destruction de la femme avide a donc
détruit la nation afghane et on a le
territoire libre d'afghanistan qui est
quand même l'objet de convoitises depuis
des centaines et des milliers de la
dernière question les français se
demandent ce qu'il faut faire et se
demandent s'il faut soutenir les
américains et se demande si à d'autres
moyens d'action
vous qui êtes afghane et qui militait
pour l'afghanistan libre et démocratique
que nous conseillez-vous
c'est très simple il faut déjà une
pression il faut arrêter de 2,2 jouer
avec les gens en recevant celui dans les
amendements d'aujourd'hui qui soit
devant le tribunal international c'est
le pakistan et le président musharraf
aujourd'hui il est reçu comme un de nos
meilleurs amis comme c'était le cas il
ya quelques mois pour les talibans donc
ça c'est insupportable pour les
allemands ça peut pas passer alors que
les afghans en afghanistan la semaine
dernière me demander tu vas faire
quelque chose là-bas pour leur dire
qu'il faut mettre le pakistan devant le
tribunal international
aujourd'hui il est ici au quai d'orsay
donc je me sens un peu faible et de
l'autre côté il ya des il faut faire de
l'humanitaire dans les zones où les gens
sont en train de mourir avec le froid
qui approche dans les zones où souvent
c'est fait pas très facile d'accès pour
les ong donc il faut y aller mais
surtout il faut aider les olives dans
les projets de développement
il faut faire en sorte que ces gens
continuent dans leur élan d'espoir et
qui continuent à être opérationnel le
jour où le pays libre ces femmes
continuent à être opérationnel au jour
plus
et libre je suis allé dans un camp de
réfugiés une femme qui me regarde dans
les yeux me dit j'ai perdu mon mari mon
frère mais tu pourras faire quelque
chose pour la petite pour qu'elles
aillent à l'école donc ça veut dire
qu'elle elle continue à croire louis si
on n'a pas le droit de les abandonner
il faut soutenir les américains alors
parce qu'ils sont blancs leur but c'est
de ces cette chose agazio pose la
question puisque leur but c'est de
détruire les talibans alors faut-il
soutenir les américains quelle est
l'opinion d'une afghane je pense que
l'opinion d'une afghane et des avancées
que l'europe puisse enfin trouver une
identité et que ne suivent pas les
américains aveuglément etc les avants
ils attendent beaucoup plus des
européens et des français aujourd'hui
depuis toujours on a dit les français
ont idéalisé massoud et tout le monde
pense que la france a beaucoup aidés
massoud choqués par ce qui est pas le
cas ce qui est pas vrai comme vous avez
très bien dit monsieur mamère dans un
article que trois mois après sa
réception ici rien n'avait bougé pour
l'alliance
donc on l'a dit pendant des années ont
été victimes de notre grand amour avec
la france mais c'est pas pour autant que
la france nous a aidés merci
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
le problème c'est que je suis pas plus
sévère avec le public de cette émission
avec mes enfants et on voit bien on va
bien je les tiens pas du tout quoi bon
alors votre bouquin très intéressant
c'est beaucoup de bruit vous montrer que
oussama ben laden n'est que
officiellement en rupture avec l'arabie
saoudite et vous dit en parlant de ben
laden qu'il en incarne plus la face
cachée serait ça fait à peu près de 30
ans que l'arabie saoudite cache son jeu
et je dirais qu'on ferme les yeux en
même temps sur sur cette face cachée de
l'arabie saoudite qui sponsorise qui
financent par son establishment je
dirais financier bancaire le
fondamentalisme et en particulier ben
laden de plus les années 80 ouais
alors si vous fait marrer vous c'est
l'histoire des demi frères quand on dit
ben laden il a dévoré frère celui dans
un pays où il ya la polygamie et
guillaume dans un pays où il ya la
polygamie ne peut pas y avoir deux
demi-frères oui c'est vrai en arabie
saoudite
quand un homme comme sheikh mohammed bin
laden le père d'osama à plusieurs à cinq
ans deux enfants avec plusieurs femmes
c'est une tribu c'est un clan et un
naturellement on n'est pas demi frère en
est membre du même clan c'est pareil il
faut comprendre avec la psychologie la
signification de là-bas pour vous ben
laden ceni un fou ni un traître par
rapport à la décennie non on dit on dit
d'ailleurs c'est le produit de son pays
à la fois religieux bien sûr le
fondamentalisme et puis le produit
financier ben laden c'est un homme
d'affaires un homme d'affaires qui a
bien réussi qui négociaient les muses
années 80 qui a été désigné par le
patron des services de renseignement
saoudiens comme représentant de l'arabie
saoudite et en afghanistan pour aller
sur le front pour recruter des
combattants
et puis qui plus tard a pu à partir de
là gagny de l'arabie saoudite faire ses
affaires toujours mais à ce moment là
dedans un dessin terroristes bien sûr
alors votre livre c'est la première
tentative d'explication disons cohérente
de ce qui s'est passé parce que jusque
là on a vu des choses on n'a pas très
bien compris ce qui se passait pour vous
tout s'explique par le contrôle des
matières premières à commencer bien
entendu par le pétrole
aujourd'hui en dehors du golfe persique
les principales réserves sont en asie
centrale
et oui c'est vrai que le kazakhstan a
été surnommé assez tôt et parler les
compagnies pétrolières américaines
then you kate le nouveau koweït france
ça en dit long j'espère que nos amis
téléspectateurs donc il ya évidemment le
golfe persique qui produit du pétrole il
ya un deuxième endroit où il ya beaucoup
de pétrole
c'est l'asie centrale pour acheminer ce
pétrole d'asie centrale vers la mer pour
venir le prendre avec des tankers
effectivement il faut faire un
'pipeline' d'un pipeline gazoduc un un
oléoduc voilà inverse organiste ans d'où
l'importance de l'afghanistan comprendre
pourquoi ce pays contrairement aux pays
dont vous parliez bernard henri lévy
dont on parle pas celui-là intéresse les
gens parce que c'est celui par roux doit
transiter le pétrole qui vient d'asie
centrale
et alors l'arabie saoudite et les usa il
ya une espèce de concurrence comme ça
pour contrôler l'afghanistan web si vous
voulez le pétrole nous aveugle en
afghanistan est effectivement l'occident
a besoin d'un régime fort régime taliban
qui est en fuite en place elle s'en
accommode
et effectivement elle ferme les yeux sur
la tyrannie de ce régime
et puis elle nous aveugle également en
arabie saoudite puis ce qu'on ferme les
yeux sur le soutien qu'apporte
l'establishment l'arabie saoudite aux
terroristes c'est très clair alors donc
les américains quand bush a été élu avec
le soutien du lobby pétrolier
alors oui je vais vous expliquer tout ça
a dit qu chesnais kendira essai puis
d'autres viennent des sociétés
pétrolières sont des gens qui
travaillaient dans le pétrole et on sait
bien que bush était élu à l'aide de ce
lobby pétrolier est pile cc public oui
alors il entame des négociations dès
qu'ils arrivent
contrairement à ce qui est à césar et
des îlots table des négociations avec
les talibans où ils disent voulu livrer
ben laden
vous participez les talibans vous nous
livrez ben laden vous participez à un
gouvernement élargi
qu'on discute au cours d'une loya jirga
avec toute l'assemblée du peuple afghan
et puis au dessus de 100 mais le roi
zahir shah voilà donc les américains
sont en train de purger donfut du pognon
quoi les américains ont commencé par
négocier avec les talibans sur la seule
chose qu'ils voulaient c'est ben laden
qui avait commis des attentats contre le
le bateau au sss colloque fera envie aux
talibans rendez-nous une partie de votre
pouvoir
on va y mettre zahir shah zahir shah
avec qui on discute depuis le 16 mai
2001 et s'il vous plaît donnez nous
aussi osama bin laden qui est ce chef
qui est tellement proche de demande à
homards et finalement c'est terrible
parce qu'on négocie avec des fondements
de fondamentalistes ont négocié comment
négocier avec finalement un pays riche
en leur promettant de l'or contre les
concessions politiques eux ils s'en
fichent d'être à l'onu ce qu'ils veulent
c'est imposé l'émirat islamique
d'afghanistan et donc ont négocié avec
le diable et peut-être perte or voilà
les américains négocient bien avant le
11 septembre 2001 avec donc les talibans
en leur disant c'est soit un tapis d'or
sur un tapis de bombes c'est à dire y
soit si on vous couvre d'or on voulait
ce gouvernement on trouve une solution
et on fait passer notre pipeline qu'il
en asie centrale soit vous bombarde
voilà si la phrase c'est une phrase qui
était prononcée par tom simons a donc
été le représentant de la diplomatie
américaine dans les dernières
négociations et ça ne manque pas de
piquant parce que après demain lundi se
déroulera à berlin
la première réunion de négociations qui
a sur l'afghanistan
et c'est précisément à berlin le 17
juillet qu'elles ont achoppé et que tom
simons a dit ce sera un tapis d'or ou un
tapis de bon voilà alors évidemment ces
négociations qui sont entamées par les
américains avec les talibans font que le
gouvernement américain relâche un peu la
pression sur la lutte antiterroriste et
c'est rassurant d'une certaine façon
parce que quand il ya eu l'histoire du
world trade center tout le monde s'est
dit bon ils sont pas très forts les
services secrets américains et quand on
lit votre bouquin on apprend qu'en fait
ils ont un peu relâché la pression et
vous parlez d'un type qui s'appelle john
o'neill du fbi qui a démissionné parce
qu'ici il a dit au gouvernement
américain
vous vous occupez pas assez
de la lutte antiterroriste moi je
démissionne le drame de la faire c'est
que ce john o'neill est devenu
responsable de la sécurité pour le world
trade center et qu'il est mort ironie de
l'histoire
ironie du sort il est mort le 11
septembre 2001 dans l'est dans les
ruines dans les cendres du wall trade
salvat c'est la conséquence logique
c'est un beuglement être à l'étranger
kid rock qui devient qui se retourne
contre nous qui deviennent un
aveuglement un terme finalement la
diplomatie américaine se dit on peut pas
à la fois s'accommoder de ces régimes et
discuter avec eux et puis effectivement
laissé faire des enquêteurs du fbi à y
aller dans ces différents pays pour
mettre en cause précisément ses réseaux
et ses pays et c'est pour ça qu'ils
effectivement malheureusement le
gouvernement américains freine les
enquêtes du fbi à y voilà et celle de
john o'neill ces négociations
n'aboutissent pas les négociations entre
les américains étaient ali ben qui
aurait donc régler le problème du
'pipeline' n'aboutissent pas et ben
laden c'est que comme c'est pas le tapis
d'or savez ce tapis de bombes
donc il dit je vais frapper le premier
on le dit aux talibans qui moribonds
américain en négociations ne le dit
clairement aux talibans et j'en ai qu
elle frappe le premier le 11 septembre
nous des aliments sont acculés
effectivement là tout s'enchaîne et
c'est bien parce que les américains donc
la négociation des américains avec les
talibans à jacques roth
oui ben laden fait son attentat du du 11
septembre
et maintenant les américains ont de
bonnes raisons évidemment d'aller
bombarder l'afghanistan tout en ouvre
les yeux voilà attendant monsieur sont
leurs grandes le rôle et on peut
imaginer qu'à l'issue de ce qui se passe
actuellement s'il arrive à contrôler peu
ou prou le régime afghan
ils pourront construire ce phénomène
high line keira d'asie centrale jusqu'à
la mer et donc à l'échelle acheminés en
occident donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on s'est tous fait avoir par la
propagande américaine
non non ça c'est ça c'est une une
opinion intime et personnelle des
produits anti américains y ont vu un
demi mois le 11 septembre et le 12 on
nous a dit voilà c'est terrible tout le
monde avait l'air très étonné tout ça
quand on lit votre bouquin et qu'on lui
fait confiance en tous les cas on se dit
que finalement voilà tout ça était pas
si surprenant illisible
une permanence est surpris que ça je
vais dire non bien sûr
non c'est ce qui est terrifiant mais
quand on dit que c'est pas uniquement il
s'agit pas d'accuser les américains
d'abord c'est pas tous les américains
c'est des intérêts américains qui ont pu
jouer un rôle qui a eu des conséquences
gravissimes
mais tous les autres pays étaient
d'accord enfin n'oubliez pas que en
décrit également la réaction du ministre
français des affaires étrangères hubert
védrine 17 juillet 2001 qui dit et donc
à l'issue de cette fameuse réunion de
berlin qui dit bon c'est vrai que ça se
passe pas ces négociations se déroulent
mal revenons voir le roi afghans et donc
et c'est vrai que quand le 17 juillet en
voie de communiqué en ligne
de quel droit nous parle-t-on et
effectivement c'est après qu'on comprend
que donc les français et également aux
prises mais il les français comme les
britanniques comme d'autres suivez ces
négociations c'étaient les petits qui
suivait mais c'est le bloc
industrialisés qui avance avec ses
intérêts et le principal financier de
ben laden on le sait aujourd'hui c'est
le numéro c'est le premier banquier
saoudien khaled ben mahfouz
il se trouve que clyde de naplouse est
connue des américains depuis longtemps
et surtout du clan bush pourquoi parce
qu'il a permis à la famille bush au père
et au fils de monter leur affaire
pétrolière au texas il les a financés à
la fin des années 70 et au mit les
années 80 alors que précisément le père
était président des états unis
c'est terrible voilà donc on est on est
au milieu de ce double jeu de ce double
langage
mais qui et schering conséquence logique
de cette histoire on a voulu on est
aveuglé pendant tant d'années
face à tous ces problèmes là
dans l'art le raisonnement qui viennent
nous est retenue laisse supposer que ben
laden aurait préparé son attentat il ya
trois semaines avant le 11 septembre
or nous savons nous savons qu'un
attentat comme celui là il ya eu
d'autres investigations que les vôtres
qui ont été faites et qui indique qu'il
a fallu des mois peut être des années
pour former les kamikazes pour former
les formes et technologiquement les
formes et moralement mentalement c'est
le travail de très longue haleine
donc moi je pense en effet que la
diplomatie américaine soit immoral
qu'elle ait commis des erreurs les
occidentaux moi je suis une première dit
moi j'étais le premier à protester
lorsque au mois d'avril ou de mai
dernier chirac et jospin par exemple de
manière à mon avis déshonorante ont
refusé de recevoir le commandant massoud
et ils ont refusé de recevoir le
commandant massoud probablement parce
qu'ils avaient des bonnes raisons
politiques peut-être du genre de celles
dont vous parlez de le faire néanmoins
je dis que ça suffit pas parce qu'ils
font pas non plus faire l'impasse par
exemple sur la dimension fanatiques
religieuses hors de toute rationalité
économique et politique d'aidé
de ben laden je crois que quel que soit
le lobby pétrolier quelle que soit
l'attitude de bush ben laden est
quelqu'un qui de toute façon est animé
par une espèce de haine ni liste de
l'occident jean-charles on n'a pas où on
a voulu s'écarter précisément du chemin
consiste à faire une thèse ou formuler
des hypothèses sur ce cette situation
qui est très complexe précisé mme on a
voulu se documenter le plus possible
avant de parler avant d'écrire et c'est
ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on a fait et quand
l'ours qu'effectivement on enquête sur
ces réseaux et qu'on voit bien
qu'effectivement il ya un mouvement si
vous les circulaires et que on retrouve
on retrouve au centre de ce cercle
effectivement l'arabie saoudite les
intérêts pétroliers des grands princes
saoudiens qui sont au coeur du
financement de ben laden quand même une
cohérence à tout ça il ya une cohérence
à tous trouvé là leur explication c'est
par le pétrole de l'asie centrale qui
est quelque chose dont on nous parle pas
tous les jours oui ça c'était plus tard
il en veut pour preuve une déclaration
conjointe de la russie et d'iran il ya
quelques jours en pleine guerre lorsque
alors que les canons tonnent encore
demandant la convocation d'un sommet
pétrolier dans la caspienne santé yalta
on se partageraient que dément le gâteau
ouais et les russes comment les russes
dont il s'apprête à matraquer des
tchétchènes pour l'instant qu'est ce que
font les russes réponse il s'apprête à
matraquer les tchétchènes se terminer
alors là avec de l'ensemble regarder
avec un blanc sable celui ça faisait
partie du deal vous soutient on vous
soutient sur ben laden et vous nous
cassez pas les bonbons sur la terreur
les alors pour être plus précis les rues
st 1 ces derniers jours surtout financer
le carburant des tadjik pour qu'ils
arrivent plus tôt dans kaboul et donc
pour inverser les plans faut en tout cas
pour chambouler les plans de
l'administration essentiellement enfin
américaine et de l'onu sur la façon dont
on allait gérer l'après d'aliments
interview vérité alors gérard bourgoin
vous êtes né en 1939 à auxerre votre
père était boucher votre grand père
aussi
et pourtant suite à un accident devait
le dégoût du sang parce qu'à l'âge de 5
ans a été renversée par une traction
avant
conduite par les allemands et depuis
vous et du mal la viande crue le sens de
j'aime beaucoup la viande
j'ai quand même beaucoup de viande je
n'aime pas cru voilà voilà c'est ça
alors à l'école n'étiez pas très bons en
orthographe
ni même à chier non mais mais mais mais
mais excellent au calcul ça c'est vrai
l'éjection calcul vous avez eu votre
certificat d'études à 14 ans et ensuite
j'ai poursuivi vous êtes 8 jusqu'en
seconde ensuite effacé ap de comptable
vous êtes devenu comme votre père
grand-père bûcher en commençant par être
commis boucher voilà alors après l'armée
l'envoient déjà vous êtes un mec malin
après l'armée vous fait le tour de tous
les patrons bouchers parisiens et vous
proposer de travailler à l'oeil pour eux
mais en même temps vouloir piquer à
chacun leurs meilleures idées rome pour
apprendre ap
ensuite vous travaillez dans la
boucherie familiale et or l'a toujours
assez malin vous mettez à concocter des
recettes que vous piquer votre mère par
exemple à la ja de lapenche à blida
c'est un truc de votre élan et les
vendre dans la région avec une avec une
camionnette petite camionnette une
petite de chevaux mais vous savez bien
sûr le vois travailler s'est fait
plaisir ce qui se passe dans ces cas là
ouais
ne
la type r super bien alors ça marche
en 63 vous installé dans une ancienne
ferme
un atelier de découpe de poulets et de
lapins de dindonneau et bientôt vous
êtes président des établissements
bourgoin voilà ça c'est le début de
votre réussite aidant la pintade
voyez les jours vous rencontrez de
caroline c'est bien le cas pardon c'est
bien plus tard que j'attende avant d'en
avant cela monsieur bourgoin ajoute
monsieur pourquoi
rassure moi c'est pas ton bien normal
et comme vous mène enfin comme demi
roumaines ont collé michèle laroque
mais je veux dire qu'elles sont bien les
grossesses dans ce pays bien gérard donc
vous ajoutez des rôtis des escalopes
prédécoupés votre production
et puis l'essor de la grande
distribution ont fait le reste parce que
vous avez été en france un des
inventeurs de ces petites barquettes
qu'on trouve au rayon frais 10 ans m les
produits de luxe au service de tout le
monde dit voilà voilà la démocratie déjà
alors type extrêmement entreprenant
quand la vitesse est limitée
vous passez à l'avion puis comme après
les avions s'il vous plaît pas vous nous
apprenez des piloter et puis après vous
avez votre ligne aérienne à vous qui
s'appelle sayo thibert serrus tamesna
donne aussi airbus qui est bien et voilà
et en 1981 vous construisez la plus
grande usine d'abattage de poulets et de
volaille et la lèque légumes poulet
[Musique]
et 90
m
vous devenez le roi du poulet gérard
bourgoin est votre ambition est de
nourrir les consommateurs mondiaux du
21e siècle
par exemple en 87 vous vendez cent mille
tonnes de poulets au moyen-orient c'est
moi le mariage la cent mille tonnes de
moi j'ai couru que poster de nuit dans
la chambre c'est vrai c'est vrai ce
moniteur bus à la partie en gros 100
milles couverts vous revoir la nature
normalement et les quarante trois usines
43 usitc beau temps d'escale 5,5
milliards de francs de chiffre
d'affaires pour combien de temps déjà y
va ça peu de temps finalement
en 20 ans en vad en 20 ans est un enfant
du trône et 35 ans de travail et valve
attendent trop de lui
les pluies touchent quelque chose je le
fais pour toi tu as mangé pouliot des
stock options bien alors en 91
c'est moins drôle et lens - drôle votre
fils se tue en avion hélas comme ils
l'avaient déverrouiller le marché et
cuba vous allez à cuba et c'est comme ça
que vous devenez ami à qui del castro
ces sages heures alors ce coup de foudre
que vous avez pour cuba vous le faites
partager à vos amis gérard depardieu
patrick poivre d'arvor pourquoi ce coup
de foudre pour fidel castro qui quand
même un type que d'un dictateur qui met
les gens en prison
fidèle c'est un mythe 1 il est
extrêmement intelligent il met toute son
intelligence toute sa finesse au service
de son peuple
j'entendais tout à l'heure qu'on parlait
de l'inégalité entre éventuellement
chant traitement et celui de du peuple
cubain y en a pas je peux vous dire il
avait chaque trois semaines j'étais
encore à la fin de cette semaine
où il avait une délégation de sénateurs
français une quinzaine rédigé par michel
charasse et je crois que ils peuvent en
faire le rapport exact il n'y a pas de
bavure à ce niveau là d'accord mais le
côté obscur de la chose ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout
mais ils bougent pas parler dingle
les gens
excusez moi donc géré bourgois vous vous
êtes je l' ai dit tout à l'heure vous
avez été le roi du poulet mais vous êtes
même le napoléon du poulet est un jour
comme napoléon s'est cassé les dents sur
moscou vous casser les dents sur
l'espagne ça a été vraiment un problème
pour vous en 92
vous essayez de racheter une usine en
espagne et à ce moment là vous avez 500
millions de pertes dit toujours que les
responsables d'entreprises doivent
prendre des risques aleris doivent être
calculées et puis de temps en temps et
bien il se laisse peut-être entraîner un
petit peu trop la politique de l'europe
qui peut être même un peu trop vite
séduit et j'ai peut-être eu le tort de
vouloir avoir raison dans les autres
puisque maintenant ça marche bien que
j'ai souffert beaucoup et que c'est pas
moi qui ai souffert mais ceux qui m'ont
succédé et qui ont été amenées
malheureusement déposer les armes
voilà alors en 94 les banques vous
demande de passer la main et c'est votre
fille corinne 27 ans qui prend la
direction ait quitté les coupes sombres
dans le budget de votre entreprise fin
du sponsoring auto fin du sponsoring du
football mais rien n'y fait les banques
vous lâche et vous dites vous même avec
beaucoup d'honnêteté d'ailleurs dit j'ai
fait des erreurs très grave
oui je découvre surtout ce qu'était ce
qu'a été ce qui est devenu un grand
succès du cinéma le placard c'est à dire
le changement du regard des autres
on vous regarde et on vous admire pour
ce que vous êtes puissant parce que vous
êtes considéré comme riche même si vous
êtes riche de dette
et puis d'un seul coup les regards se
détournent et c'est là qu'on apprend
vraiment à voir ce que sont les hommes
et ce que sont les vrais amis regardent
maintenant que dans la merde t'es sympa
je suis un peu plongé la vie privée
permettre alors vous dites non vous
dites justement même quand on est riche
de dette
et c'est vrai les causes de la
catastrophe c'est ça c'est des fonds
propres
inexistant beaucoup d'emprunts 1 100
millions de frais financiers par an un
peu comme tapis vous avez monté un peu
votre affaire avec l'argent des autres
on peut dire non je crois que si vous
voulez il ya les constructeurs ouais il
ya les récupérateurs d'entreprise j'ai
jamais profiter les affaires des autres
j'ai tout créer chez tout con c'est vrai
tout monté et un j'étais très fier
d'être à la tête de 7000 salariés ma
grande fierté aujourd'hui c'est de les
avoir encore très souvent téléphone et
de les avoir beaucoup autour de moi et
ils m'ont beaucoup aidé à passer le
monde difficile et continue à m'aider
beaucoup a possiblement difficile près
rien n'a rien en 2000 dépôt de bilan en
redressement judiciaire le groupe est
vendu 150 millions de francs il y avait
quand même un milliard de pertes
finalement c'est ce qui me paraît le
plus important c'est de savoir que 90 %
des emplois ont été sauvés et
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises vivent
on peut dire avec un coefficient de
remplissage total et un les maires qui
continuent à avoir les entreprises dans
leurs communes sont très fiers de
continuer dans les taxes
professionnelles avant l'escale des
salariés qui chaque matin mon travail
alors vous êtes plaint de problèmes
après avait été accusé d'abus de biens
sociaux d'escroquerie de faux bilans été
mis en examen
à cause de quoi ça je comprends pas vous
c'est un je crois que les banques ont
toujours de beaucoup de mal à digérer
leur père y avait beaucoup de sentiments
pour prendre un milliard cent millions
l'intérêt ils en ont ils ont eu pas
beaucoup de
très peu de pudeur a tenté de vouloir
démontrer qu'il y avait eu détournement
de biens je sais exactement où j'en suis
j'avais dit dès le début que je ne
craignais aucune question du juge je
reste dans la même optique je fais
complètement confiance à la justice
française
d'ailleurs un qui me laisse vivre
complètement ma quiétude totale et qui
je dois le dire fait très bien son
travail
oui ce qu'il faut dire si vous avez été
associé dans une affaire de pétrole à
cuba 1 et que vous avez les riches vous
dirigez toujours cette société vous
n'êtes plus actionnaire je suis plus
actionnaire moi je la dirige parce que
votre associé obtenu la saisie
judiciaire de vaud par les associés et
les banques
ouais les associés quand je serai le
bénéfice départ ce sont les banquiers
français
ouais vous détruisez la paix et de
pardon il a perdu du pognon à faire du
pétrole à cuba n'ont rien on ya passé
dix et l'action ravira les seuls
européens
c'est notre astérix au réveil de l'huile
de noix ou alors ce qui est le plus
incroyable et vous à nous expliquer en
fait c'est que malgré tout ça vous êtes
quand même élu président de la ligue
nationale de football
malgré tout ce qui peut être racontée
ici ou là j'ai jamais fait aucune erreur
de gestion j'ai dirigé pendant 25 ans la
jia d'auxerre
un club qui est parti de rien et qui est
aujourd'hui où il est pour l'amener là
où aller et je crois que le moment venu
comme il fallait un libéral la tête du
football on m'a demandé de l'être et
c'est comme justement vous êtes un
libéral êtes partisan de la cotation des
clubs de foot en bourse
je suis surtout partisans si vous voulez
de respecter la loi française la loi
française a imposé aux clubs de football
professionnels de se transformer en
société anonyme
on peut pas d'un côté et leurs maîtres
l'obligation qui est liée aux sociétés
anonymes et d'autre part ne pas le
remettre les droits
ces sociétés anonymes et parmi les
droits il ya les moyennes se financer
partout dans le privé dans
l'institutionnel et bien sûr dans les
parcs publics alors cotation des clubs
en bourse fiscalité allégée soral de
teint libéral propriété indivise
ul des droits alors évidemment vous en
pensez quoi vous cette privatisation du
foot et cette libéralisation du foot
c'est pas tout à fait d'accord je pense
qu'on mélange un peu trop d'argent et de
sport mais bon il ya sans doute des
décisions qui vont être prises dans un
avenir prochain notamment pour faire
payer des droits de retransmission des
événements sportifs notamment radio
ouais on radio publique très franchement
je suis pas sûr qu'on soit sur la bonne
voie d'abord ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que le droit à l'information ne saurait
et de bafouer qu'il est tout à fait
normal que tout le monde puisse tête
gratuitement informé par la voix du
journaliste de presse de radio de
télévision des résultats des sports de
l'existence d'un match mais à partir du
moment où à travers un spectacle qui est
celui du sport professionnel on crée des
journaux et on fait des journaux avec
des partenaires qui sont des parrains
avec des partenaires qui sont des
publicitaires et je parle ici devant un
grand homme de télévision et de médias
c'est ce que fait d'acheter des bd qui
sait ce que c'est exact et des droits et
je crois que ceux qui achètent les
doigts de nous affronter de bafouer ce
que vous dites clairement c'est si c'est
pour les résultats bien sûr il ya pas de
problème si c'est pour raconter le match
à la radio ou raconter le match dans un
journal faut payer mais je crois que
tout est clair que vous en pensez quoi
raymond je pense qu'il n'est pas sain
quand même que tout cela soit dominée
par l'argent voilà je comprends qu'un
certain nombre de spectacles
on soit contraint de les payer mais le
sport est quelque chose que les français
et d'autres attendaient ils ont besoin
je crois de pouvoir suivre des matches
sans être obligé de passer à la caisse
moi je trouve ça allait passeront à la
caisse les gens les radios c'est le
patron de la radio et les moyens
d'information passeront à la caisse et
d'une certaine manière faudra bien que
quelqu'un paye viendra pas cet esprit
sur le président le français payent
l'impôt est fait pour ça le français
paye ne l'oublié pas à les chaînes
publiques soit financée par l'impôt
allègrement et canada le patron de radio
france est pas content du tout vous
savez ça ouais mais jean-marie il a une
position totalement différente lorsqu'il
s'exprime dans les médias seuls que
lorsqu'il est avec moi et qu'on discute
de l'avenir justement de ces fameux
droits radio et je peux vous dire qu'il
n'ya pas d'équivoque là dessus et guerre
monsieur jean marie cavada sait très
bien où il en est et personnellement je
le sais également bien alors on va
revenir sur vous aujourd'hui donc vous
gagnez 8600 francs par mois parce que
vous avez beaucoup d'argent qui est
saisie à la source
heureusement il ya la ligue nationale de
football vous avez un loyer que pas très
cher vincent les deux francs par mois
qui est payé par la ligue
une 607 de fonctions plus les frais les
repas voilà mais pour quelqu'un qui
travaille depuis l'âge de 15 ans et dure
comme vous avez travaillé c'est pas
terrible non mais je crois que si vous
voulez après 47 ans de sécurité sociale
je vais avoir droit ma retraite elle
vient d'ailleurs d'être débloquée le
mois dernier parce que je n'ai pas droit
de retrait en passes pour 69 saviez pas
que d'une petite bavure vous savez j'ai
de 57 ans 60 a été alarmé au moment de
l'algérie et
il ya eu un petit trou dans ma carrière
qu'on n'arrivait pas à reconstituer
parce que j'ai fait vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure beaucoup de patrons dans la
région parisienne certains n'avaient
peut-être pas tout à fait les
déclarations pour estimer la risée je
vous rassure je suis pas venu pour faire
le procès de la sécurité sociale les
caisses de retraite tout et ajouterait
bien il en a fallu il a fallu quatorze
mois mais tout est assez mal avec le blé
qui la veille dans la bien planqués qui
peuvent pas nous prendre pour des cons
quand même on l'a dit on l'a dit on l'a
dit on l'a dit on l'a dit vous le savez
celle là on a dit que celui qui dit
oignons au canada ce gel doit pas
ralentir alors en les prenant pour des
cons une image une image qu'on termine
et vous vous souvenez vous aviez une
baraque sublime et dans cette barre à
xavier fait creuser à l'inter la baraque
une piscine est à côté de la piscine
vous aviez mis un bio de boucher pour
montrer à tous vos invités tous vous
veniez vous l'a toujours la piscine la
piscine fumer chez touchant le bio
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc j'en rêve qui s'écroule après vingt
ans de patinage je vais jamais été
blessé aussi gravement sahara non je
n'ai jamais été blessé quelques petites
entorses avec dix quinze jours d'arrêt
mais vraiment rien de grave
ouais le problème que vous avez stéphane
c'est comme ça on peut le dire parce
qu'on le sait cet ensemble dans la vie
pouvait pas trouver une autre équipe
hier vous non et puis j'ai signé avec
elle dès le départ et puis voilà c'est
comme je n'avais que schild ce sont les
bienvenus
alors on est obligé de vrais de fer avec
donc je m'entraîne tout seul un peu
triste mais c'est comme ça en plus c'est
elle qui vous tire est d'une certaine
façon
comment ça non non c'est vrai que l'on
peut dire c'est vrai sarah une plus
grande soif de réussite que vous c'est
le cumul est toujours aller de l'avant
donc calé
et elle est très meneuse et nous a fait
quand même quelque chose qu'elle se
blesse comme ça ouais vous dites
d'ailleurs ça va mater sortir de mon
trou grâce à elle je suis devenu
quelqu'un donc pour ça que je dis ça
ouais c'est vrai que les sortir de mon
trou mais je suis encore le perche
professeur bigard peux pas trop bouger
les effets que le matin
à
alors dès votre arrivée à paris vous
avez été admise à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière vous été opéré par le
professeur saillant donc celui qui avait
opéré ronaldo mais c'est vrai oui
j'étais dans la chambre juste à côté on
s'était même sachant gérer un mois et
demi de plâtre avant de commencer la
rééducation et vous d'un dévouement
absolu vous passez vos nuits à ses côtés
pendant le temps où elle était à
l'hôpital de la salpêtrière mais disons
que je m'attendais à vivre le plus beau
jour de ma vie j'ai vécu le pire
donc c'était très difficile et qu'il
soit à mes côtés à mon chevet lors de
l'opération il est à l'hôpital après il
est resté avec moi toute la nuit c'était
quelque chose à moi très bien le
règlement qu'est que ça qui va lui faire
la ribouldingue
un oui appuyé remarquer quand on a
touché le fond on peut que remonter
après toute façon que je me tienne ligne
bah ouais on s'attaque à des milanais
des remontées bien sûr bon viendra ici
le problème c'est que c'est
malheureusement pas fini puisque
l'annoncé tardive de votre forfait
aurait permis aurait permis un didier
gailhaguet
le patron de la fédération française de
maintenir la juge française
marie-reine le gougne et c'est elle qui
contre toute évidence a déclaré
les russes vainqueurs au détriment des
canadiens bien entier
non mais nous notre problème principal
quand sarah été blessé ça a été de la
faire rapatrier très rapidement parce
qu'on nous a dit qu'elle pouvait pas
rester comme ça et notre forfait
c'est donc à partir de là c'est eux qui
s'occupent aussi tardivement la
déclaration de votre forfait à leur
demande et malheureusement des kayaks et
oui parce qu'on parle d'arrangements
entre la france vous le savez entre la
france et le bloc de l'est pour faire
gagner le couple tricolore
gwendal peizerat et marina anissina ce
qui arrive quelques jours plus tard
l'ours a déclenché un scandale énorme
enfin tout le monde tout le monde a
parlé c'est le cas de le dire
protestations du canada enquête les
russes hurle en disant qu'on est revenu
au temps de la guerre froide ont saisi à
une affaire d'état
massé a rarement est en fait autant de
scandales et donc j'espère que tout va
pas se régler parce que ça salit un
petit peu l'image de nos sports qui bien
sûr qui est pourtant magnifique on est
vraiment des on est des vrais sportifs
s'entraînent de six heures par jour et
c'est c'est dur de devoir entrer dans
les jt entre nous après qu'il a fait
exprès gailhaguet ne pas signifier tout
de suite votre forfait pour pouvoir
garder
marie-reine le gougne qui elle allait
voter évidemment pour les russes qui
après aller voter pour les français
franchement on peut pas on ne peut pas
on est en train c'est pas qu'on ait pas
au courant mais il enseigne aussi la
russie ne veulent rien faire
on était dans un contexte qui nous
permet de
ce n'est pas que ça là ils font du sport
six heures par jour
des sportifs ne sont pas des businessman
qui non mais bon il ya eu des pressions
d'ailleurs marie-reine le gougne dit
avoir dans un premier temps elle dit
j'ai favorisé virus elle avoue avoir
favorisé des russes sur instruction de
monsieur gailhaguet et après elle s'est
rétractée mais enfin bon allez subi des
pressions web de gaillac et est
d'ailleurs finalement le cio le comité
olympique international a donné
également une médaille d'or aux canadian
finir comme chez jacques martin tout le
monde en a 10 des femmes est le seul
point positif de la faire c'est qu'il ya
une nouvelle façon de juger maintenant
donc au lieu de neuf juges viennent aura
14 c'est mieux c'est moins bien et moins
bien partout c'est l'ordinateur qui
choisira l'ordinateur choisir à quel
juge
mais ils sont parfaits de la voir du
coup les juges ils pourront très bien
mettre une note très bas si on ne dira
pas leur nombre encore pire oui ça
permettra à toutes les tricheries ce
coup ci lève pas toutes les tricheries
mais disons que je pense que j ai su
l'international skating l'une a fait ça
pour tourner les pleurs de problèmes
avec les justes et on pourra plus on ne
pourra plus s'en prendre aux juges
pendant et ça a été fait ça on s'en
prend à un ordinateur
voilà encore
walt est sacré la fécule qu'on a déjà
remboursé c'est la faute à l'ordinateur
et ça c'est lamentable parce que sur
l'ordinateur il écarte des juges
honnêtes et qu'il garde et pilou ça sera
encore pire car c'est n'importe quoi je
ne pense pas que je sais que ça ne va
pas de voter alors je veux dire quand
même une chose c'est que derrière les
sourires et les paillettes le patinage
c'est un monde assez dur cela peut se
régler à coups de couteau tu te souviens
de la sphère kerrigan harding et vous on
peut dire aussi il ya un an j'étais
victime d'un coup de cutter la veille
d'une compétition dans une chambre
d'hôtel championnats du monde à nice
voilà vous êtes en train de regarder la
télé on seul coup de cutter sur le
couvert le bras sans demander que j'ai
pris un coup j'ai la porte s'est
refermée
c'est elle se referme automatiquement et
j'ai vu une silhouette mais
malheureusement j'ai dans ses filets en
plein coup de cutter et ne put plus un
coup de fil plus rien et l inde aussi
des plus beau jour de notre vie sportif
était quatrième après le programme court
on jouait le podium c'était les
championnats du monde en france à nice
donc on se pose des questions
hélas la voilà on voit la nature le cerf
à vis de bol j'ai dit tant pis faut
patiner faut y aller alors voilà et vous
êtes allez vous devez gagner voilà c'est
extraordinaire on vous arrache donc donc
ça va ça s'est arrangé
c'était très bien mais ses fans étaient
à deux doigts de tout lâcher il arrête
il n'arrêtait pas de pleurer et m'a dit
comment je vais faire pour te porter
comment jean pierre est bon on a fait
une piqûre et santé - son bras il a pu
me porter mais c'était vraiment un
moment très difficile est d'avoir gagné
la médaille de notre vie un roman
feuilleton
bigard 48 heures avant bercy il est sur
un scooter il ya une gonzesse qui pile
devant lui dit ap un nom mais j'essaye
moi j'ai c'est dur mais je suis très
sensible ce qui est arrivé à sarah parce
que c'est c'est terrible comme de se
préparer pendant toute une vie
et puis de se péter le tendon d'achille
est comme moi je pense que il faut
trouver quelque chose de bien tout ce
qui arrive et là j'ai vraiment du mal
pour eux là je me dis que vraiment ou
alors je me dis 20 que c'est vrai que
dans deux ans ils vont
au top niveau et qui va peut-être y
arriver tous ensemble on peut plus rien
changer à ce qui s'est passé et encore
on peut pas les annuler les jeux bana
c'est trop tard soit avalé le temps est
maintenant
d'ailleurs on voudrait remercier de sa
rare sur en façade moi ça m'a beaucoup
étonné mais des centaines des centaines
de lettres de gens qui nous ont écrit et
donc je voulais leur dire que s'ils
veulent avoir des nouvelles de sarah bon
d'un site notre site qui s'appelle
hiver.com ils peuvent
on a des nouvelles tous les jours de
sarah donc voilà je vous dire un truc
c'est pour ça que vous êtes là ce soir
c'est que je vous ai vu à la tv quand
vous êtes arrivé à l'aéroport j'ai vu
votre tête et jeudi à catherine barma
faut vraiment qu'on invite tout s'est
écroulé d'un coup on reste s'écrouler
sans le moment c'était vraiment très dur
d'ailleurs d'en reparler c'est difficile
mais bon j'ai mon rêve maintenant c'est
devenir championne d'europe championne
du monde et peut-être championne
olympique en 2006 j'espère je n'aurai
plus mal avec la niaque que vous avez
vous allez on vous le dira
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fatima belhadj bonsoir vous êtes donc
l'ex épouse de loïk le floch prigent qui
a été successivement pdg de rhône
poulenc pdg de l et pdg de la sncf
vous jetez plutôt l'époque elle alors
ben dans l' affaire elf lui il a eu 28
mises en examen six mois de prison
préventive
il ya eu un procès qu'on a appelé le
procès du mcee pas le procès elf à quel
procès d'humains il a été condamné votre
ex-mari à trois ans et demi de prison
ferme et à 2,5 millions de francs
d'amande
bon il ya eu appel et dernièrement quand
il ya eu donc l'appel dans ce procès
dumas votre ex-mari était absent il
avait une pancréatite il était dans une
clinique du liban et le mettre un chef
de cette clinique du liban a dit que son
état de santé n'était pas gravissime
quand il était avec vous est ce qu il
avait déjà des problèmes de pont créa
jamais non jamais est-ce qu'il avait
déjà du psoriasis
oui elle est déjà bien alors votre
ex-mari se donnent des nouvelles va
beaucoup mieux
il a quitté la clinique au liban hasard
gâte le 11 mars
voilà il va bien il est pas rentrer en
france
c'est un petit peu le problème parce
qu'un expert qui l'attend pour
l'examiner mais il n'est pas rentré
l'expert veut pas aller au liban donc
voilà on est un petit peu embêté est ce
que vous pensez vous qu'il connaissait
bien pour avoir été son épouse
est ce que vous pensez qu'il est en
fuite non je peux pas vous dire s'il ya
but ou pas je crois pas compliqué dans
le contexte penser qu'il va revenir
j'ai pas j'ai pas de réponse là dessus
parce que j'ai vécu avec lui un certain
nombre d'années il sans vraiment le
connaître
ouais alors il vous acquittez loïk le
floch prigent il ya presque dix ans du
jour au lendemain
vraiment
lundi jour au lendemain on va en parler
alors il était ici loïk le floch prigent
il ya six mois et voilà ce qu'ils
disaient tout bas et ça c'est l'erreur
met d'accord
1 c'est à dire à simon ex épouse et
leurs épouses actuelles normes et des
pousses de cette période mais je suis
resté neuf mois marié c'est notre pretty
mandela et auquel elle l'utilisé
beaucoup la carte de crédit de f1 est un
peu trop trois cent mille balles
d'europe quand même bien le fisc est
passé ne vous inquiétez pas pour le
contribuable que le contribuer à ce
problème très bien ne pas trop là mais
pour moi il ya un problème effectivement
ceux ci n'auraient pas dû être fait
alors les 19 millions de francs qu'elle
a touché lors du divorce qui les a payés
il n'ya pas lors du divorce dire lors du
divorce personne n'a pu toucher pas que
ce soit ces quatre ans après qu'elle
reçoit cette somme il après le divorce
moi je n'ai plus aucune relation entre
amis sirvin catia v4 et ses copains et
l'appartement à londres ça c'est premier
duel c'est un appartement alors on ne
sait jamais s'il appartient à la femme
ou à villeurbanne on n'en sait rien on
est d'accord ce serait bizarre il est
présent ouvertement c'est aux nerfs de
voir ça ça m'énerve
oui ça m'attriste surtout pour ça c'est
pathétique c'est surtout c'est plus de
la tristesse que oui ça m'agace aussi
les sur vous fait quoi de le revoir un
petit pincement de coeur ou plus rien du
tout dix ans passés ouais alors pas
vraiment impatient car vous les
rencontrez des jalles est comme ça
les plus charmants fatima bella il vous
publier cette semaine un livre qui
s'appelle au coeur de l'empiré lf une
épouse encombrante chez michel lafon
vous avez choisi tout le monde en parle
pour en parler merci interview vérité
[Musique]
alors votre livre est dédié à votre fils
nile ce qu'est né d'un premier mariage
et que le floch prigent considéré
pendant toute la période où il était
avec vous comme son propre fils alors à
part les jours parler de votre vie vous
aimez à bordeaux au milieu des années 50
votre mère est allemande et votre père
algérien alors votre maire au début de
la guerre elle s'est engagée dans la
croix rouge delà de la wehrmacht et un
jour elle va témoigner à la police dit
j'ai vu des juifs qui étaient
électrifiés sur des fils de fer barbelés
et la police lui dit que si je continue
à dire des trucs comme ça elle est en
prison
donc elle s'enfuit d'allemagne elle va à
bordeaux de maria votre mère là elle
rencontre un dénommé belhadj qui est
originaire de tizi et à ce moment là il
ya beaucoup d'algériens qui arrive en
france pour reconstruire le pays à 7
après la guerre alors coup de foudre
totale entre entre beaux parents au
mépris de l'exclusion dont était victime
mais évidemment après la guerre non
seulement les allemands mais en plus les
algériens alors vous venez 155 vous
grandissez dans une hlm à l'école est
victime de votre différence oui bien
beaucoup de racisme à l'époque
quand un jour j'ai les doigts pleins de
haine et qu'on essaie de me l'enlever de
force à dire de l'école et que je lui
dis que ça ne part pas et quelle magie
des me dit cité par an sont pas contents
ils n'ont qu'à retourner chez ben bella
oui bien on vous traite de choix de sale
[ __ ] à cause de votre mère soit de sale
[ __ ] à cause de votre s'est pas créé
loin après la deuxième guerre 110 ans
après la libération se donne des
migraines 1 pendant toute votre
scolarité vous avez des migraines à
cause de ça et en plus de ça vous voyez
souvent votre père qui est emmené en
pleine nuit au commissariat et qui le
lendemain matin revient avec le visage
en sang fut très difficile pour vous
cette époque parce qu'on vous explique
que vos ancêtres sans les gaulois
apparemment vous y croyez pas trop hein
difficiel préféré de che guevara
angela davis alors qu'on jette à fond là
très révolté vous êtes lcr trotskyste
vous êtes lutte ouvrière
et puis un jour déçu par le militantisme
vous accepter un emploi de secrétaire
ça vous plaît pas non pas vraiment ce
que j'avais envie de faire mais compte
tenu de la scolarité que j'avais eu
enfin ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs de plus
en plus souvent aujourd'hui c'était un
peu une voie de garage au parti de chez
vous vous allez en allemagne et là vous
rencontrez un dénommé peter vous
installer tous les deux à avignon lui
bosse dans une imprimerie
vous vous occupez de nils l'enfant que
vous avez avec lui et alors là me sortez
tous les soirs entre amis à avignon et
c'est comme ça que vous rencontrez un
barbu de 36 ans avec des beaux yeux
bleus père noël vous avez le prix jean
voilà alors il ya une idylle inédit le
kiné
mais deux ans plus tard quand vous
séparer de votre ami allemand peter lui
vous invite dans un chalet dans le jura
vous faites des grandes balades tous les
deux ans passés le grand amour oui on
est amis avant avant qu'il ne devienne
mon amour bon il suppose évidemment
apprécié ce moment là vous voyez surtout
d'ailleurs au départ pendant les
vacances et puis en 88 en 1988 vous
venez vous installer à paris il en est
en juillet 89 êtes en vacances avec lui
à taormina et là vous devenez bon
évidemment amis amants mais aussi
presque vous êtes sa confidente quoi oui
très proche il vous fait part de ses
doutes il vous fait part de son enfance
de ses problèmes de jeunesse de ses
parents oui c'est quelqu'un d'assez
secret en fait il est très très peu
d'amis qui se confier très peu et moins
parler ouais donc si je suis d'autant
plus atterré par ce qui se passe ensuite
alors il souffrait beaucoup d'avoir eu
un père indifférent et au contraire une
mer très possessive
d'ailleurs cette mère vous la rencontrez
un jour évidemment elle est pas très
contente que son fils lui ramène
quelqu'un comme vous un jeu se passe pas
très bien le contact est très froid elle
vous fait manger un plat de fèves et
puis lorsque vous dites c'est le genre
de gens comme ça breton catho qui
passent leur temps à tricoter des pulls
pour les africains mais qui parle aussi
sans arrêt de la suprématie de la race
blanche quoi c'est un peu difficile à
supporter dans tous les cas et puis je
me rends compte qu'elle a une attitude
plutôt méprisante
c'est pas je ne suis pas là même si
qu'elle avait rêvé d'avoir quelques
temps plus tard mitterrand nomme loïc le
floch prigent pdg de elf pour vous est
ce surtout les rangs rouge arrive que la
fameuse campagne de l'epa connaissent un
jour dans toute la france il ya eu une
marque et les ronds rouge arrive il y
avait des ronds rouges
non c'est parce que j'étais encore dans
toute la bretagne et marquer le pétrole
arrive c'était total
loïk le floch prigent devient à ce
moment-là pdg de elf qui est la première
entreprise française 7 milliards de
francs de bénéfices soixante seize mille
employés
là il ya un grand moment c'est le jour
où il va prendre possession de la
tourelle et ils vous emmènent dans ce
qui sera désormais son bureau c'est au
dernier étage vous dominez tout-paris
fait un peu les rois du pétrole on
pourrait dire oui probablement moi non
je l'accompagnent je crois qu'il avait
envie de faire partager ce moment qui
est importante pour lui et là il vous
confie la création d'une fondation
humanitaire la fondation elle à la fois
pour redorer le blason de la compagnie
et parce que si les les épouses des
chefs d'état africains avec qui elle
fait en contact font tout dans le
caritatif dont il pense que c'est une
bonne idée de vous donner sa wii presse
qu'il soit s'est créé une fondation à
vocation humanitaire afin de redorer le
blason de la compagnie et puis
d'apporter une aide humanitaire dans les
pays où s épuisent le pétrole un don qui
me demandent de m'en occuper et
j'accepte enfants alors lui vous pousse
effectivement inventé cette fondation là
que alfred sirven qui est dubitatif où
il ya le fret pense que c'est pas une
bonne idée
et d'ailleurs on va voir par la suite
que c'est pas vraiment une bonne idée je
suis exposé et qui a des gens dans
l'entourage de loïc qui ne supporte pas
que je sois à cette place là bas c'est
vrai en même temps que vous devenez un
personnage quasi officiel de la
république le floch prigent vous emmène
partout avec lui dans un falcon 900 un
avion extraordinaire qui est un avion
appartement à la deux jeunes donc vous
fait la tournée des maîtres de l'afrique
noire les dîners les réceptions comme
une revanche pour vous quand même sur la
vie non c'est pas une en revanche c'est
un peu félix est un rêve c'est long
voyage vous pouvez ensemble et je suis
en fait ils souhaitent que je
l'accompagné dans tous ses voyages et
c'est plutôt atypique parce que jusqu'à
présent on n'a jamais vu un président de
compagnie a mené sa femme comme ça
avec lui dans tous ses déplacements et
voyages officiels
il veut vous emmener ce que c'est par
exemple parce que comme vous êtes
d'origine algérienne il revendique le
fait que j'aille algérienne ça quelque
part c'est une provocation pour lui
voilà et puis ça lui permet aussi des
contacts peut-être plus facile avec les
pays du tiers monde où elle puise son
pétrole non c'est possible mais je pense
qu'à l'époque il était très épris d'un
même si aujourd'hui que c'était une
grave erreur une satire erreur je pense
que ce soit plus une erreur à mon avis
stratégiques mais pas eu une erreur
amoureuse je pense qu'il est il avait un
grand plaisir à m'avoir avec lui le
béguin pour quoi mais quand on vous voit
en comprendre alors en 90 vous vous
mariez alors le week end de 9,7 à
marrakech la mamounia
ensuite j'ai la new york pour
l'introduction du groupe elf en bourse
c'est l'hôtel pierre kg soit centrale
par ja c'est quand même une super vie
partout moscou l'asie centrale le qatar
vous prenez un appartement de 300 mètres
carrés rue octave feuillet à paris un
duplex avec terrasse
c'est venu un jour oui c'est la même vie
c'est fantastique mais il ne trouve pas
assez beau l'appartement de la rue
octave feuillet alors il prend un hôtel
particulier rue de la faisanderie 45
millions de francs
il avait d'autres projets enfin
1 il souhaitait acquérir un appartement
quelque chose qui lui appartiennent on
était très bien votre taf juillet alors
en plus il pourra encore un deuxième
hôtel particulier ça c'est vrai pour la
fondation 1 rue dumont d'urville pour le
voit la paille plus en plus mégalo quand
même faut dire à ce moment là non je
pense que quand on accède à un poste d
contente de pouvoir il dit lui-même
qu'il avait plus de pouvoir qu'un
ministre on perd un peu la tête
ils se déplacent plus qu'avec un cortège
de voitures gyrophare mais pour aller
acheter le pain il se croit invulnérable
à ce moment là oui je crois qu'ils
pensaient général rien un problème si
ces quatre points il ya un problème il
ya un problème c'est que danielle
mitterrand qui a fait la fondation
france libertés elle prend un peu on
brasse de la fondation elle est ou fait
une erreur
elle vous envoie un jour son ami son
grand ami raphaël du web qui vous
propose quelque chose et vous les
conduisait il voulut danielle mitterrand
ronsard dit oui en fait moi je ne prends
pas trop vous seriez ce qu'on me raconte
quand on me dit que madame mitterrand
est agacé qu'elle me raconte qu'elle
elle pense que je veux absorber la
nation france libertés je ne peux pas
imaginer une seconde qu'elle puisse
croire ce genre de choses je pense que
plus il ya de plus il y est demeuré
sociation oui voilà il ya mieux leurs
portes
donc je prends pas vraiment au sérieux
et quand raphaël dois bien me voir le
budget de l'année est déjà bouclé ce
qu'ils me proposent rentre pas du tout
dans le cadre des attributions de la
fondation et j'ai refusé
vous savez que c'est un grand ami de
danielle mitterrand rappelle du web
oui alors il ya un dîner quête organisée
rue de bièvre c'est madame mitterrand
elle même qui vous appelle ensuite un
dîner au large et anaky et tings rénale
en lan dumas là vous découvrirez loïk le
floch prigent très cire pompes avec le
présent la république
mais bon c'est pas les seuls tout le
monde avait envie de plaire au président
personne ne bosse la parole pendant ce
dîner personne donc moi j'y vais parce
que elle se retirera insiste j'ai pas
vraiment envie d'y aller continu des
relations un peu tendues avec madame
mitterrand je comprends pas vraiment le
son invitation et j'accepte parce que si
on va me dis que le président veut
absolument faire ma connaissance alors
au retour loïk le floch prigent vous
prend la mare hier la voiture il est
assez peu nous vous dites dans votre
livre
et puis la halle des rumeurs commencent
à accourir sur vous on vous accuse de
vouloir balancer est ce que vous savez
sur les détournements de fonds au sein
de de l' affaire elf
on vous accuse donc de demander de
l'argent en échange de votre silence on
vous accuse même de faire partie d'un
réseau de call-girls et d'avoir été
recruté par tarallo le grand adversaire
de sirven pour séduire loïk le floch
prigent
alors on raconte beaucoup de bêtises à
cette époque des tas de rumeurs en fait
que loïc et elle ferait des enfants
eux-mêmes courir en en même temps pour
justifier en fait le fait que j'allais
être répudiée juste après je dois
finalement alors vous accuse de
capricieuses oui vous avez fait changer
la la moquette de votre bureau parce que
vous n'aimiez pas la couleur
non j'étais allergique ont fait là je
suis allergique à beaucoup de produits
3com et je suis allergique à la colle
donc j'ai supporté pendant trois jours
et puis le quatrième on a changé
on a enlevé la colle et on a reposé la
moquette
alors elles sont là ça a l'air d'aller
mieux vous partez en vacances aux usa
langat et larmes d'hackett code et tout
devrait aller bien et aux moments comme
ça vers la fin des vacances vous trouvez
que loïk le floch prigent est pas très
bien il est dans un profond désarroi
il vous fait des sourires de façade et
puis quand vous approchez de lui qu'il
est au téléphone vite ça va moi mais
tout va bien moi je sentais qu'on fait
ça va pas non ça va pas il a préparé son
départ et je la prends ensuite quand
l'instruction a démarré d'ailleurs que
il a déjà pris un appartement à dans la
maison d'ailleurs qu'il a commenté jane
plan bien précis pour me quitter il n'en
laisse rien paraître pendant ses
vacances aux usa alors au retour vous
partez deux jours à avignon chez votre
copine
irène et quand vous revenez à paris les
affaires de loïk le floch prigent ont
disparu de l'appartement et là vous
arrivez plus adjoint où j'ai essayé de
l'appeler il est pas là et sa secrétaire
me savoir que de toute façon il veut
plus me parler qu'elle a reçu des ordres
et je reçois dans la soirée la visite de
maurice bidermann qui me dit que loïc
veut divorcer et qu'il faut que je
démissionne de la fondation très
rapidement je refuse parce que ce que je
veux c'est voir mon mari à l'époque y
avoir une explication je comprends pas
son départ je la raison de sa fuite
je ne sais pas pourquoi il est parti
aussi brutalement il n'y avait pas de
conflit entre nous il n'y en avait pas
de problème je crois qu'on avait on
avait sûrement des problèmes comme tous
les couples mais pas de quoi se séparer
sans allemand on avait été amis pendant
longtemps je pensais bien le connaître
et s'il avait voulu me quitter parce que
il tique les amoureux qu'on ne pouvait
plus vivre avec moi pour des raisons
affectives personnel mais attend des
tendances et les nuits ça s'est toujours
très bien que ça se passait très bien
il me dit c'est votre mari ça se passe
bien il n'y a pas de souci et du jour au
lendemain et vous quitte
quand vous revenez l'appartement et
vivre chinois
il a vidé sa il a vidé cia puis ces
affaires les affaires de son fils ont
disparu de la chambre il ya même le vit
bien et pas un mot d'explication à ce
moment là on vous accuse d'avoir piqué
un million dans lesquelles la fondation
est le jour voulu vérifier tous les
documents ont disparu voilà parce que je
refuse je refuse on ne divorçait de
démissionner de la fondation et je veux
je fais savoir à montvillers man que le
lendemain je me rendrai au bureau et que
j'irai travailler comme d'habitude dix
mecs ça je crois pas que ce soit une
bonne idée parce que figurez-vous qui
sembleraient qui manque un million dans
la caisse fondation et on vous accuse d
avoir pris donc j'ai dit il mais je
serai au bureau demain et je ferais je
réunirai le conseil d'administration en
plus fréquente après compte et on verra
que rien n'a disparu
et quand j'arrive lendemain matin à la
fondation un on refuse de me laisser
rentrer il le garde du corps m'empêcher
j'appelle maurice bidermann jeu finit
par entrer et quand j'arrive dans mon
bureau c'est comme à la maison
le bureau a été vidée j'ai plus aucun
document même plus mes agendas même plus
mon quart des notes personnelles plus
rien non non c'est un vrai cauchemar
voilà c'est un vrai cauchemar alors là
je sens une lettre sur mon bureau de
monsieur match tels qu'ils étaient là
pour vous plus que je vais appliquer
complètement donc cette lettre me dis
que les mêlées mémoire de l'ordinateur
des ordinateurs ont été effacés il n'ya
plus les statuts ya plus les comptes ya
plus rien et qui veut qu'on va faire une
enquête de police qui va en référer au
président
de la compagnie alors partir de là elles
vont tout faire pour faire accepter le
divorce de mort
andré guelfi un jour vous convoque au
bar du ritz
dédé la sardine et ils vous montrent des
documents estampillés police nationale
qui parlent du passé de vos parents de
vos problèmes psychiatriques de votre
vie dissolue et même de partouzes voilà
alors ce qu'il ya c'est choquant c'est
que
sur le passé tout est absolument exacts
sur la vie de mes parents tout est réel
c'est ça c'est exact c'est la qualité
et puis quand on arrive au présent je
fais des partout dans mon appartement je
m'occupe pas de mon fils j'ai un
comportement aussi de quelqu'un n'est
pas tout à fait normal je suis épuisée
surmenés et finalement ce qui me
conseillent ah oui et on conseille de
partir dans une maison de repos que je
dois accepter ce divorce que j'ai pas
d'autre choix et que si je continue sur
les positions je serais probablement
donc enfermés et que l'oit prendre à la
gare de mon fils il y avait police
nationale sur ces documents et police
nationale sur les documents donc c'est
ce qui me choque le plus là on vous
explique que loïk le floch prigent est
prêt à faire enlever l'enfant à vous
donner de l'argent en suisse
si vous acceptez le divorce on vous
propose 15 médian voilà en attendant
c'est plutôt tranquille par mois de
temps en temps mais vous avez eu des 15
millions pour finir d'illizi alors vous
en vous menace d'accident
aussi on peut vous menace continent oui
parce qu'à l'époque en fait je veux
raconter pendant le président de la
première compagnie française traite sa
femme
les menaces les pressions pour me faire
divorcer enfin en bas de chez moi il y
avait une voiture avec deux types en
permanence qui surveillait mon téléphone
était sur écoute et certains se faisait
un plaisir de me rapporter les
conversations j'avais eu les endroits où
je t'ai allez donc j'avais menacé à un
moment donné de parler un journal et de
raconter ce qui m'arrivait et là on m'a
dit d'abord que
tout le monde s'en foutait de mon
histoire est que ces personnes ne
croient risque que je pense à l'époque
parce que l'histoire est tellement
abracadabrante que je pense
qu'effectivement personne ne va me
croire contenu aussi que régulièrement
on me dit que je suis pas celle des
strict je suis un peu d'accord vous en
parler à rené quand vous en parler à
celui qui était encore votre mari à
l'époque il vous répond ça nous dépasse
on n'y peut plus rien enfin je vais dire
qu il al air de finalement d'être sous
influence
oui voilà moi j'ai connaissant le loïc
que je connaissais à l'époque
j'imagine pas un instant qu'il ait pu
partir comme ça de son propre chef
donc je suis moi persuadé qu' on le
pousse à divorcer et la confirmation
entre guillemets parce qu'il y en aura
d'autres après mais la première c'est
que lorsque j'essaie de faire a en fait
un geste parce que ce que je souhaite
moi c'est qu'on puisse expliquer c'est
quand même là on avait qui je vis avec
qui je me suis mariée que j'aime à
l'époque j'ai envie de comprendre ce qui
nous arrive je lui envoie nous quel sort
pour son anniversaire et à ce moment-là
ça l'a visiblement touché il me
téléphone en fin de journée du bureau
pour me dire que il a été très touché
par les fleurs et puis abandonné la voie
ce caceis pleurs et parce que je lui dis
moi mais enfin ne laissent pas les
autres régler dans histoire parce qu'on
est jeune et affaire qu'à des
intermédiaires c'est à dire que moi il
disparaît et je ne leur vois pas c'est
alfred sirven trucks qui me dit à un
moment donné en tapant du poing sur la
table
vous ne reverrez jamais votre mari s'est
terminée si vous avez un compte à régler
c'est avec moi je lui réponds moi mais
c'est pas avec vous que j'ai été mariée
je veux parler à mon mari c'est un vrai
cauchemar en fait
et à ce moment là lui me dit mais ça
n'est plus je lui dis régler nos
problèmes entre nous s'il te plait bien
par l'otan et il le dit mais ça n'allait
plus entre mes mains et ça nous dépasse
et je ne peux plus rien faire et je ne
s'appellerait plus ça me fait trop mal
ça s'est dernièrement le sincère que
j'ai dû avoir
finalement vous accepter le divorce
et vous partez en palestine vous partez
à gaza a retrouvé vos racines arabes
pour vous reconstruire et vous dit à
gaza finalement j'étais moins en danger
qu'à paris et puis voilà et puis ensuite
il ya la mise en examen votre mise en
examen est la première d'ailleurs dans
la sphère l1 et loïc vous mais à partir
de là toutes les sommes dépensées sur le
dos et si oui c'est facile de justifier
ainsi les ces débordements financier
peut sommairement sur personne trois
cent mille ça me parait drôlement
démesuré mais c'est vrai qu'il m'a
accompagné acheter des robes et compte
tenu de la position qu'il avait et je
l'accompagné dans tous ses déplacements
je vais à être un billet assez marrant
cette république où tout le monde fait
des courses ensemble il ya christine
deviers-joncour qu'accompagner du match
et chez berluti me loïk le floch prigent
qui vous accompagnent cette attention
fatima bellaïd il ya trois solutions la
première c'est qu'effectivement loïk le
floch prigent a appris des choses graves
sur votre passé la deuxième c'est que
vous savez des choses que vous ne riez
pas du savoir et la troisième c'est un
ordre de mitterrand que loïk le floch
prigent n'a fait qu'accepter sans
discuter
quelle est la bonne réponse la troisième
voie c'est que c'est mitterrand
absolument diallo peul prigent il faut
que vous quittez cette femme absolument
et d'ailleurs beaucoup de protagonistes
dans le dossier vient et des
personnalités pas des moindres sont venu
le confirmer
pourquoi retrouver pourquoi parce que
j'étais trop présente que c'était la
première fois qu'à sa naissance était
atypique dans ce milieu c'était la
première fois qu'un président de société
de cette importance en plus amenés son
épouse avec lui dans tous les
déplacements
donc c'est les voyages officiels
j'assistais à des signatures de contrat
et je pense que certains avaient peur et
se méfier de ce que j'avais pu entendre
des confidences que loïc aurait pu le
faire
donc j'étais gênante merci
[Musique]